nous sommes à la ferme du cabriolet près
de sainte maure de touraine indre et
loire comme tous les mardis sébastien
clerc accueille des élèves d'une école
primaire de la région depuis 2009 ils
produisent des fromages en nature
biologique non lacaune et cher donc
l'idée c'est de vous faire brouter
l'herbe n'est pas cru parce que
finalement on peut pas vous faire mon
devoir creux d'un prix les pasteurienne
autres stations déjà le goût
alors on va faire deux groupes il ya un
groupe qui va avec sébastien qui va
donner à leur petit bébé
et puis où le groupe on va les faire des
fromages
alors ici vous avez vous avez une
vingtaine de chevrettes alors ce que
vous allez faire avec moi vous allez
m'aider c'est qu'on va les nourrir
on va faire de la cuisine
on va vérifier la température parce
qu'en fait c'est comme les bébés ainsi
on donne le biberon trop chaud le bébé
va avoir mal au ventre
c'est bon bien voir ça tu es avec le
fouet et tu va remuer pendant qu'on
verse d'accor asie comme en sarre mais
voilà le but en fait c'est de montrer
aux enfants comment on nourrit les
animaux et puis de leur montrer que les
petits ont besoin de lait et comme ici
on est un élevage laitier on leur prend
le lait donc il faut bien leur donner
autre chose à la place
le seul endroit on ne peut pas rentrer
ces deux laboratoires
c'est ici qu'on transforme cinquante
mille litres de lait par an pour faire
du fromage qui sera commercialisée en
direct
on va prendre son petit lot de fromage
on va le rouler comme ça on va le faire
tomber une fois on va le faire tomber
une deuxième fois et après on peut
manger
d'accord balas et des tout-petits donc
ils vont comprendre quelques notions
comment on fait du fromage parce que
c'est quand même pas facile ils ont
trois ans quatre ans les plus grands je
pense donc que c'est surtout comprendre
que pour faire du fromage il faut du
lait il se passe quelque chose de
magique où ça se transforme et puis
qu'on met du sel est lassant pour qui
une croûte déjà s'ils ont compris ça
c'est super et puis après il ya tout le
côté gustatif parce que nous aussi on
veut comprendre que l'enfant comprenne
que l'on fait les bons produits comment
ça se passe dans une autre sphère mois
alors voyez ya
trois bassines différentes dans chacune
des bassines vous voyez qu'il ya des
choses qui sont pas les mêmes et on va
faire une petite recette pour les chefs
parce que dans leur repas elles ont
trois éléments différents en ce moment
et la visite va se terminer comme chaque
fois par la nourriture des chèvres
céréales et oléagineux bio évidemment un
exercice que des enfants adorent
pour sébastien laventure remonte à 2009
avec bac + 5 en gestion de pme et une
formation au lycée elle décolle il
décide de s'installer encouragé par sa
compagne claire salariés dans une
commune voisine et des militants de
l'association terre de liens qui vont
collecter auprès d'une centaine de
personnes sensibles à l'économie
solidaire ce qu'ils appellent l' épargne
citoyenne pour lui permettre d'acquérir
22 hectares de terres et 65 cher
pour le bâtiment il obtiendra un prêt de
220 mille euros sur 15 ans de la nef
banque solidaire et du crédit coopératif
les banques ayant refusé de lui financer
vous présenter mon projet aux banques
suite à une étude qui était tout à fait
favorables et dans un premier temps
apparaissait intéressés et puis dans un
deuxième temps j'ai
j'ai essuyé des refus
retour au siège crédit agricole et
banque populaire donc j'ai jamais on n'a
vraiment jamais expliquer les raisons
vraiment du refus
bonjour sébastien
en as tu toujours au boulot
depuis qu'il a reçu deux soutiens de
terre de liens sébastien a régulièrement
la visite des membres de l'association
qui viennent s'assurer que le bail
environnemental l'obligé à faire du bio
est toujours respectée une fois que
que la terre est acheté par terre de
liens avec le système d'actionnariat
citoyens la terre reste propriétaire de
terry bien l'objectif de terre de liens
est temps de mettre ses terres à l'abri
de l'agrandissement des fermes
existantes et aussi à l'abri de la
spéculation
de l'urbanisation l'artificialisation
c'est à dire que ces terres restent
terres agricoles est cultivée en bio je
me suis dit oui dans le vaste champ de
ss l'économie sociale et solidaire
parce que en premier
l'activité en agriculture biologique les
respectueuse de l'environnement et puis
de nos concitoyens et puis ensuite on a
quand même un des liens privilégiés
locaux avec nos les consommateurs
notamment dans les groupes d'amis
fidèles à leur engagement sébastien est
clair organise chez eux tous les mardis
une amap un marché solidaire auquel
participent 35 familles des environs qui
ont passé commande à une quinzaine de
producteurs locaux
aux produits tout en bio on essaie
d'utiliser toutes nos céréales pour pour
faire le pain et autres on essaye de
tout produire sur place quoi en fait je
suis la maraîchère de la map
donc c'est moi qui fais les légumes de
saison toute l'année pour les adhérents
on essaie de de participer pleinement à
la vie de la ferme et du projet qu'on a
monté avec sébastien à la fois avoir à
travailler à l'extérieur parce que pour
l'instant la ferme ne fait pas vivre
toute la famille elle fait vivre
sébastien et une salariée à mi-temps et
puis bah en même temps développer
l'accueil pédagogique c'était quelque
chose qui me tenait à coeur
cinq ans après leur installation
sébastien éclairs ont gagné leur pari en
prouvant qu'il est possible de produire
bio dans l'esprit de l'économie sociale
et solidaire